trois signatures pour mieux lutter
contre l'insécurité qui touche le monde
agricole dans les yvelines
cette convention permet de mener
davantage d'actions entre les gendarmes
et les exploitants agricoles l'accent
est notamment mis sur la proximité en
fait on formalise des bonnes pratiques
un des bonnes pratiques qui ont déjà
lieu notamment en termes de par exemple
de prévention des vols avec des
gendarmes qui sont spécialisés dans le
conseil aux agriculteurs c'est à dire
qu'ils vont aller dans une exploitation
agricole
et ils y vont faire des préconisations
d'équipement vidéoprotection en
fermeture de porte en tout ce qui permet
de ralentir en fait aux délinquants pour
l'année en cours on dénombre une
vingtaine de vols dans les exploitations
agricoles du département
le matériel agricole vos extrêmement
cher c'est à dire que pour un ordi d un
tracteur et un tracteur agricole c'est
plus de 100000 euros donc une
moissonneuse batteuse c'est le prix
d'une maison à peu près donc quand vous
avez des engins qui ont une valeur de ce
type là dans les exploitations ça ça
vous montre qu' il ya en plus qui sont
mobiles c'est pas comme une maison donc
qu'ils peuvent se déplacer pour nous le
l'aspect sécurité devient très important
une convention particulièrement
importante pour le département des
yvelines
composé à 40 % d'exploitations agricoles
est à peu près mille agriculteurs et ça
je parle de des exploitants agricoles
mais après vous avez toutes les familles
tous les sous traitants tous ceux qui
travaillent avec les agriculteurs donc
ça fait effectivement un nombre
considérable de personnes qui sont
concernées par cette convention
reconductibilité convention pourrait
intégrer de nouveaux volets destiné à
renforcer les liens entre les gendarmes
et les agriculteurs